to truly enjoy a good tailgating party
you've got to have some good meat and if
you want to take it to the highest level
you got to have outstanding barbecue and
that's why roland smoke is here mike
moore is the gm of roland smoke he's
here to talk about a big raiders
tailgating slash watch party this
weekend where people can get uh good
football hopefully with the raiders
playing the chiefs let's hope an amazing
barbecue absolutely that's the goal you
got competition going absolutely a
little bit of a competition we've got
some folks driving in from kansas city
to compete with us it's kind of like an
us against them chiefs kingdom versus
the raiders nation so we're going to see
who's the best in barbecue there's
tickets starting at ten dollars we're
going to be cooking ribs on sunday and
doing sauce so we're going to be judged
on both our ribs and our sauce and we'll
see how it goes they've done something
like this before and had like a thousand
people show up right exactly it's big
events um this event is going to be at
starbase it's within walking distance of
the stadium so we're excited there's tvs
on multiple tvs with all the games going
on beverages both
for adults and others and then there's
going to be plenty of good barbecue the
air is going to be full of smoke yeah so
mike it starts out at 10 bucks but 35
bucks now you get all the barbecue right
exactly there's several packages you can
even pay an extra 25 and become a judge
if you want to so yeah i got issues with
that i got issues you shouldn't you
shouldn't have amateurs judging barbecue
well you know everybody thinks they're
an expert people coming in from kansas
city they think they're the best so
we'll see right right you were saying
you were saying there's kind of uh
kansas city you know kansas of course
they're known for barbecue texas they
kind of exactly like look up look down
their noses said anybody outside of
those states who's vegas right we'll see
yeah but they haven't had your barbecue
exactly and why are the ribs so far away
from me right now mike that's the
question is did you know that i would
probably consume them and there was a
memo on the caution i get it that's the
memo that's passed along to every guest
especially when barbecue comes in how
long you've been doing this now
oh seems like my whole life um but for
about eight years now rolling smoke
we've got five locations including one
at um raider stadium and one inside
t-mobile arena so we've been very
blessed we're thankful that everybody
loves what we do well congratulations
all your success again uh star starbase
and if people want to find more
information can they go to a website
eventscue
eventsq
you can find it on facebook or
eventsq.com and it's on 3905 west diablo
all right you'll be able to smell the
smoke i love it all right have fun this
week